um
do you have like when you're when you're
locked up right you gotta help me
understand this because
what like how did you entertain yourself
throughout the day
as far as your free time was it
meditating was it reading
because you guys don't got the internet
and [ __ ] out over there nah reading
where i have people playing music on the
phone you guys like different
technically the phone's contraband right
yeah yeah but on a regular phone right
right right right oh so people would
play using [ __ ] over the phone
phone so that's how i know about a lot
of stuff yo what's the worst song you
heard over the phone
oh a song that i really just did
like you're like wait that is it
a lot of [ __ ] that came out since you
got locked up that you're like hmm
that's interesting yeah i was just
it's from atlanta so that's all
oh i have an idea who it is
i know the truth let me see i have an
idea who lives it's crazy
that's a tall guy i don't know
boy he's a nice guy yeah i mean that's
why i don't do all that i didn't like
it though that's fair shout out to
you whatever
anyway i don't care whatever um
i just grabbed that out of thin air
didn't it yeah he getting money though
that's all that matters he got he got a
nice head on his shoulder yeah